now we made the crumble please be
careful okay Carol first very very hot
take your sugar on there okay into your
pan okay now flatten it out okay keep
that pan just give it a shake okay good
now once that's in there turn off your
potatoes okay and put the kettle back on
again leave that Carol getting really
nice and dark okay
rhubarb time that's on day pages are
still on yeah they're young you got the
wrong knob there you go camels fine
right get a bowl yeah you put something
in there with this I don't know yet no
number not yet now just got a bowl
nothing at all
okay here we go rhubarb time now put the
tree stick together okay watch your
fingers you want them cut about a
centimeter apart
okay now the chopping knife okay good
girl come on pass even a great job they
are cast are you guys dessert what's
your fingers going are you dessert
person I love pudding yeah like my
council that's nice nice nice nice right
you get a bowl Annalise oh sweet they
cheat they think luck so checkers in
here okay sodas are off completely right
ginger at the ginger into the rhubarb
and this is where I went to be really
careful camels working if the pan is
getting really hot wrap the cloth around
your hand and just turn that round
now be careful the stall you'll it we
burn please please please yeah handle
with caution get your bowl Patsy yeah
okay
very well buddy
okay shoes put me off right okay
I always trucking those shoes always
amazing rhubarb into the pan okay now
okay give that a little stir okay be
very very careful it's very very hot
okay again just a little stir okay okay
now very carefully get a small knob of
butter okay we pass the butter okay
just like Novelli a small knob now get
the butter now that gives a nice loss
the caramel okay and I want you to toss
the rhubarb in the caramel okay gently
very gently okay good girl excellent
great tosser now okay from there take
your rum please be careful
I want the thumb on the end of the
bottle okay over the pan its flambe time
yeah here we go
right okay here we go ready thumb over
the end and over be generous over
okay
okay okay first trust me I won't melt it
down